les téléphones portatifs sont interdits
j'avais le droit aux calculettes
il
alors les volos à prendre une grosse
branlée j'avance savoir si tu as peur tu
vas faire quoi
faux la mention très bien sinon je peux
pas partir à londres qui est sujet ici
et on trouve quelqu'un qui nous les
torts sur la dernier minute mais qui ont
saisi la fille de la femme était sur le
mec qui tuent des gens
on peut négocier quand même on négocie
rien du tout démonter comme un lego et
je vais terminer comme un climat
maintenant commencé les repérages
sécurité du rectorat petite vérification
des installations
les sujets seront conservés ici si vous
tapez 3 fois de nouvelles combinaisons
parce qu'en plus long qu en règle
oh non je vais vomir voisins la
formation de bars et a vu les doses que
tu as mis dans le vert de brice maman
c'est bien mignon tout ça mais on peut
quand même on parle tradition n'est pas
plutôt envie de savoir ce qui se passe
dans le lycée
je crois qu'on a trouvé notre spiderman
annuler sa remake des 69 68 quoi mai 68
à 69
intermat